qu'est-ce qui fait de Martin Scorsese le plus grand
de tous les temps ouais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements] [
Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci,
pouvez-vous trouver les loups
sur cette photo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
J'ai une question pour Leonardo  DiCaprio,
de votre point de vue en tant qu'acteur et
cinéphile, qu'est-ce qui fait de
Martin Scorsese le plus grand de tous les temps
ouais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements] et
bien sans aucun doute euh
je ne peux pas parler seulement d'un
point de vue personnel ayant grandi  les regarder tous les
deux, euh
d'un point de vue cinématographique, comment cela
influence non seulement tout ce que je fais en tant
qu'acteur, mais aussi les
niveaux artistiques incroyablement élevés qu'ils ont
pu accomplir ensemble dans cette
relation
ne m'ont pas seulement changé, c'était aussi le cas.  le
modèle pour moi, il a influencé
toute la génération d'acteurs
avec laquelle j'ai grandi et que puis-
je dire, c'est que là se trouve
la persévérance de Marty et
sa férocité et sa volonté de dire la
vérité sur ces histoires aussi laides
que bizarres non  peu importe à quel point
sa maîtrise et son
respect pour l'
histoire du cinéma sont inconfortables, ce qui a été fait avant
lui,
l'influence des grands réalisateurs
de son passé qui ont fait de lui le
réalisateur qu'il est
est tout simplement sans précédent et il a su
se définir  en tant que
réalisateur singulier de notre époque et
il continue de faire
ces films incroyables qui racontent des
histoires importantes comme ce film.
Je suis
comme vous tous, je suis constamment
impressionné par sa capacité à continuer à
dire la vérité de la même manière.  il le fait avec
ses personnages et avec ses histoires
[Applaudissements]
ensemble